il y a pire environnement pour se faire
vacciner le célèbre et très chic centre
commercial comme a été transformée en
clinique pour les moscovites une piqûre
avec vue sur la place rouge
un mélange de prestige et fierté à
l'image du spoutnik v le vaccin de la
victoire comme on dit si développé et
produit en russie m 50
mariam et de recevoir sa deuxième dose
et on souhaite autant des amis canadiens
qu'il envie énorme de stand de sino
forest et a toutefois que c'est un
canadair vérification faite le vaccin
russe ne fait pas partie de la stratégie
de santé canada à long terme mais il
s'affiche désormais comme l'un des
grands favoris de la planète j'ai pris
l'initiative d'envoyer une mission
scientifique en russie luronne qui avait
pourtant fait une croix sur le spoutnik
à l'automne vient de se raviser
elle étudie aujourd'hui scouts né dans
l'espoir qu'il soit approuvé mêmes
produits sur son territoire d'ici le
printemps
c'est pas une décision politique c'est
ça que il faut comprendre peut-être mais
le spoutnik b qui avait fait l'objet de
méfiance et de railleries quand vladimir
poutine l'a précipité avant même que la
recherche doit compléter s'avère un
véritable triomphe politique et
commerciale pour le crémant
[Musique]
depuis car vu de 27 à confirmer son
efficacité
mills des vacances pour nivet raineau
seube les achats se multiplient de
l'amérique du sud au moyen-orient domine
pour l'heure à ses côtés à ramallah en
cisjordanie cycling de recevoir en
cadeau les premières dix mille doses des
100000 commandé par les autorités
palestiniennes est mort après fort de
belfort en plus d'être efficace plus
positive et est deux fois moins cher que
celui de modern art où deux failles sur
explique ali abed rabbo des autorités
sanitaires
je pense que quelque chose d'important
justement dans ces deux est de
reconnaître qu'en cas de l' influence
politique
puis d'essayer justement de ramener le
focus sur la la la la santé publique
mondiale mais dissocier la géopolitique
de l'urgence sanitaire n'est pas acquis
pour tout le monde
l'ukraine l'enfant pauvre de l'europe a
fait le choix de bannir le vaccin
heureuse de son territoire
même s'il est à portée de tous ceux qui
se tournent vers le scout n'ont pas vu
leurs territoires volés et leurs
citoyens agressés par la russie nous a
dit en entrevue le ministre de la santé
est faite in the end pas question
citoyens midi même si c'était la seule
option dans le monde je m'en prive si je
crois que laisser la russie comble
élevés dans le monde est un dangereux
précédent
il faut se rendre à l'évidence que le
spoutnik v est devenu un outil
incontournable pour lutter contre la
pendule en mai par m le scout ni canton
tout premier satellite la russie n'a
jamais caché son jeu le pari est énorme
une taille payant malgré la terre
navalni les menaces de sanctions le
scout les pièces en or b plus populaires
à l'étranger qu'ici même en russie
et si thammarat et et restaurants du
canada aussi